Bladesmiths, welcome
to our strength test.
Another fan favorite,
the log chop.
What I'm gonna do is
take each of your blades
and perform 10 strikes
on this chunk of wood.
This is going to test
the strength of your edge
and the overall construction
of your knife itself.
Rich, you're up first.
You ready?
I am.
Let's have some fun.
RICH: I intentionally
made my knife heavy,
so it would get through
the chopping test well.
[chopping sounds]
[rock music]
About an inch and 3/8 there.
RICH: OK.
Good job.
Thank you.
JUDGE: This did very well
cutting into that log.
The one thing, that handle--
it was very uncomfortable.
It was really putting
pressure on my fingers
there, trying to hold onto it.
But it cut very well.
The edge is still razor sharp.
It's nicely done.
Thank you.
Kelly you're up next.
You ready?
I'm as ready as I'm gonna get.
Good enough, then.
[chopping sounds]
[rock music]
JUDGE: Made it down about an
inch and a quarter, Kelly.
Nice.
Your edge held up great.
It's nice and sharp.
Right now I feel like I'm in
the battle of the giant handles,
though.
It's very rounded, so
those last few strikes,
I was trying not to have
the blade twist in my hand.
But your edge held
up, so good job.
Thanks.
What you think, Dave?
You ready?
Yep, go for it.
[chopping sounds]
[rock music]
JUDGE: Went down
an inch and a half.
Good job.
DAVE: Thank you.
JUDGE: Cut very well.
It was actually very
comfortable in the hand.
No rollovers, no shiny spots.
Very nice job.
Thank you.
Now I'm going to pass you off
to Doug for the sharpness test.
To test your
blade's sharpness,
I will cut through
the ham three times.
If it's held its edge and is
sharp, it should cut cleanly.
Rich, you're up first.
You ready?
I am.
[dramatic music playing]
DOUG: Well, Rich, the grip was
a little bit big and blocky.
The weight of the weapon
is a little bit heavy.
But then again, it cuts
cleanly without even
having to use power.
It's a very sharp
edge right there.
This, sir, will cut.
Thank you.
Kelly, you're next.
Are you ready?
Yep.
DOUG: Let's do this.
[dramatic music playing]
Well, Kelly, it glided nicely
and sliced across the meat.
The issue I have here is a
little bit on your handle.
The area that you
have your bolsters on,
it really digs into my finger.
Overall, though, it's got a nice
feel to it, and it is sharp.
This will cut.
Dave, you're up next.
Are you ready?
Yes sir.
[dramatic music playing]
Well, Dave, the
balance on this blade,
though, it is light and fast.
And, as you can see,
it lacerates clearly.
Your handle
construction is smooth.
It feels good in the hand.
But your decorated
piece over here?
If you were a
left-handed practitioner,
it could be a little bit
of an issue for that.
Overall, it will cut.
Good job.
Thank you.
HOST: Bladesmiths, your
weapons have been tested,
and the judges have
evaluated your work.
It's time for one of
you to leave the forge.
Kelly, your blade
did not make the cut.
JUDGE: Kelly, you did a
great job on your blade,
but the real problem
was those bolsters.
The bottoms were
so sharp that if I
hadn't been wearing
a glove, it would've
really cut into my hand.
And if a handle's
going to hurt the user,
then it's not really
a functional weapon.
HOST: Kelly, you have
to surrender your weapon
and leave the forge.
To be up against the
clock and to put on a handle
that I'm happy with is
clearly not my strong suit.
But I got to compete with
some really great guys--
and see that time clock again.
[laughs]